and a new way to study depression may
lead to more treatment options for
patients a book just published in the US
it's called the inflamed mind a radical
new approach to depression examines a
link between inflammation in the body
and mental health it recommends that
doctors considered patients physical and
mental histories it's estimated more
than 16 million Americans suffer at
least one major depressive episode a
year mood disorders like clinical
depression are also the third most
common cause of hospitalizations in the
US for adults between the ages of 18 and
44 the author is Edward bull Morrie's a
professor at the University of Cambridge
in England he heads a psychiatry
department there and he joins us this
morning at the table good to see you
Adam owning that hole more and let's
start about the connection between
inflammation and depression first I
think you should just give a brief
history about what inflammation is yeah
and how they're connected
okay so inflammation a lot of people
will be familiar with it's the body's
kind of first line of defense against
attacks so if you've got a infection in
your finger let's say it becomes red
swollen it's obviously inflamed what
people may not understand is that that
is just the tip of an iceberg there's a
kind of systemic inflammatory response
cells inflammatory cells it spreads
throughout the body exactly in body and
that's how it can get into the brain it
can send a signal to brain that changes
our mood and behavior what is the
research show about the connection
between inflammation and depression okay
so we've known for a long time there's
an association you know inflammation and
depression go together if you've got
arthritis psoriasis inflammatory bowel
disease for example all inflammatory
diseases of the body your risk of
depression is going to be much increased
the new understanding is that that
association could be causal it's not
just a coincidence the inflammation
could actually be directly causing the
depression and that's a new
understanding that we didn't have if
inflammation found in all those who
suffer from depression none and that's
very important because we're not talking
about a kind of one-size-fits-all
solution to depression I think that's
probably been one of the reasons why we
seems a little therapeutic progress in
depression over the last 20-30 years
it's not just one thing
I think the inflammatory component is
probably going to be important for about
a third of patients with depression and
then there are a lot of other patients
whose primary diagnosis isn't
psychiatric you know they may have
arthritis as I mentioned already about
a quarter of those will also have
depression so it's not everybody but
it's gonna be quite a lot of people can
you be having an inflammatory response
to something and not know it yes and
what would that be what condition would
that be well lots of conditions couldn't
cause relatively low-grade inflammation
that you might not realize that you have
for example in the book I talk a lot
about dental problems those can cause a
low-grade inflammation you might not
realize it was there
obesity is another cause of low-grade
inflammation stress social stress can
cause inflammation the body something we
didn't understand 5-10 years ago so
there are many factors that wouldn't
amount to a disease wouldn't necessarily
having have you going to a physician and
saying I've got an inflammatory disorder
but if you do a blood test there would
be something we do know about the
connection between inflammation and
heart disease yes you know about
inflammation and dementia that recommend
connections between those things so the
question we have is and this is
something I've recently become very
interested in as anti-inflammatory foods
and this and drugs that we can take
natural drugs what are they how can we
reduce inflammation yeah well it's a
critical question and as you point out
we now understand the inflammation is
much more important in many different
areas of medicine than we did 20 30
years ago so this is another area of
change now what can we do about it
obviously there are already a lot of
anti-inflammatory drugs out there and we
need to do the trials we need to show
that they can directly impact on
depression there's some circumstantial
but easy ones like exercising every size
you don't smoke yeah you talked about
medical apartheid that does really it
which I thought was a very strong phrase
it is a strong player we really need to
look at this differently well because I
think treatment I think we're a bit
split I think the way that we think
about things moment with the mind and
the body being quite apart patients
going to see different doctors different
hospitals for treatment of mental and
bodily symptoms I'm not sure that's to
the advantage of the patients and I
think we need to break down that barrier
between mind and body and thinking about
the inflammatory links yes and the way
that the immune system can communicate
from the body to the mind is in one way
that we can break down that apartheid as
I say preach Edward bull more yeah
yeah yeah thank you very much I
appreciate you coming the inflamed mind
is on sale now wherever you like to buy
your book